occasionally fox news host chris wallace
will bring us some kind of like heroic
journalism by american standards but
it's really what in other countries
would just be called
journalism and today's is perfect
because it shows us how easily a talking
point that spreads like wildfire
can be exposed and debunked if reporters
are actually willing to do it and many
many are not or at least they're not
well prepared enough to do it and the
talking point in this case is that
stimulus checks are going to prisoners
republicans have among other things been
saying
democrats and joe biden are sending
stimulus checks to people
in prison and some senators
say it and then right-wing media says it
and then before you know it it's being
repeated by
you know republican voters and diners
the likes of which we saw
in clips earlier today the truth of
course
is that prisoners got stimulus money
during the first covet stimulus package
and during the second covet stimulus
package it's how they work
it's not set up to exclude people who
are otherwise
income eligible just because they're in
prison now
maybe it could be done logistically but
a court has actually said no you can't
do it
and so radical republican senator tom
cotton
uh pulls this bullet point and chris
wallace confronts him
check out tom cotton's defense and chris
wallace
confronting tom cotton with his own
previous words here
here is one of your other complaints
about the the covet relief bill take a
look sir
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance
on saturday morning to stop checks from
going to prisoners
from going to the boston bomber for
instance and on that vote
they declined every single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
but senator under two previous coveted
relief bills that you supported and
voted for and that president trump
signed
prisoners also got checks in those bills
well chris that was obviously never
congress's intent the trump
administration irs and treasury
department
did not send checks to prisoners liberal
advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge said they had to
last month was the for this month was
the first time we ever had a simple up
or down vote on whether those checks
should go to prisoners
and the simple fact is that every
democrat voted to keep sending checks to
prisoners
i don't think that's a smart idea i
suspect most americans don't either
so notice how tom cotton tries like a
mini gish gallop there
gish gallop is where you throw a bunch
of stuff out and it sort of altogether
sounds like wow that's a lot but then
when you start going through each claim
you realize there's nothing there
first tom cotton concedes okay yes
stimulus checks went to prisoners during
trump's
covet stimulus number one checks went to
prisoners during trump's covet stimulus
number two
and now checks are going to prisoners
during the third stimulus under joe
biden but says tom cotton
during the first and second ones it
wasn't our
intent we didn't want them to go to
prisoners
this time democrats do want the checks
to go to prisoners it was never their
intention he says
but they did it twice and then they only
are making a big deal out of it
the third time when joe biden is
president and democrats control the
senate
but then tom cotton says this is the
first time we actually
had an up or down vote on it and it
passed well
that's because you guys controlled the
senate before
and you didn't want an up and down vote
but more importantly the up and down
vote this time was irrelevant
because it's already been decided on
previously by a federal judge
the irs inspector general previously
after
i i believe it was after the second
stimulus bill might have been the first
i think it was the second
the irs inspector general confirmed
that they did send checks to prisoners
during one of the earlier stimulus
packages
and because there were no restrictions
on people in jail or prison getting the
money
the irs later was pressured to change
their position
and the irs said you know what prisoners
don't qualify
for the relief checks and if anybody got
one they should send the money back
so prisoners filed a class action
lawsuit against the irs and the treasury
secretary
and a federal judge ruled on this in
september
the court ruling said you can't withhold
coronavirus relief payments
if prisoners qualify from an income
standpoint
just because they are incarcerated a
federal judge decided
so this up and down vote now was
meaningless in the end and recall that
prisoners have to buy their own
hygiene products they pay exorbitant
rates just to make
phone calls that's another big scam that
preys on prisoners which we've talked
about
give them the stimulus money guys we're
talking about stimulus money that went
to hundreds of millions of people
there's a couple million prisoners uh
that this that this applied to
let's not stand in the way but more
importantly tom cotton is such a
hypocrite
and his defense is so you know i
i i want to say it's so obviously bogus
if it weren't for chris wallace saying
whoa whoa whoa stop the clock
here a lot of people probably would fall
for tom cotton's explanation and in fact
many people do because
they see chris wallace and they're like
that's like when shep smith was on fox
he's the one guy you can't trust on fox
news that's unfortunately the
perspective
of of many of these uh right-wing fox
viewers
but the talking point falls apart
so quickly and yet it still spreads like
wildfire so
nice job mostly by chris wallace this is
just kind of called journalism in many
other countries but i would have liked
to see him push back even more